CATHERINE DRENNAN:
So at MIT, there
are several options
of chemistry courses.
Everyone has to place out of
chemistry or take one semester,
and even if you're going
to be an economics major,
you need that
semester of chemistry,
and there are several options.
And this particular
course is designed
that if you don't have a very
strong background in chemistry
or maybe if you do but maybe
it's not your favorite subject,
that this is one you can come
in and take even if you haven't
taken chemistry before.
And the backgrounds are
actually quite diverse.
There are absolutely students
who have never taken it before.
There are other students
who have taken two years who
probably could have taken
a more advanced class,
but they thought
this one sounded
like it would be more fun.
So there's quite a bit of
mixture in terms of background.
A lot of people
coming in are not
that excited about
chemistry, and this
was one of my tremendous
surprises when I taught here.
I realized in high school not
everybody is jumping at the bit
to take the chemistry
class, but at MIT, these
are scientists and engineers.
Everyone walking
through the door
should be in love
with chemistry,
and I discovered that
absolutely was not the case
and that it was my job
to help convince them,
these people who were
generally interested in science
and engineering, that
chemistry was important.
And I just thought
it was obvious,
but then I had to remember
back to my experience,
and it wasn't obvious to
me the value of chemistry
the first time I stepped
in a chemistry course.
So on the first day
of class, I like
to show a picture from
my college yearbook,
a picture of myself and
college yearbook picture of one
of my classmates who
is Lisa Kudrow, who
is Phoebe on Friends, and I
put both of our pictures up.
We were in the same class, and I
asked them to guess who we are.
They usually get it.
And then I ask
them to guess what
I went to college to study.
They guessed chemistry.
I tell them drama.
I ask them to guess about Lisa
Kudrow, and they guessed drama,
but it was actually
biology, and she
was a biology major at Vassar.
And so then I said,
how did this happen?
How did I become a chemist
and she become an actress?
And I let them know
this because I said,
you may have come to
MIT to study something,
but that might not be
what you end up studying.
You might be taking this
class because it's required,
but that's just
because you have not
found your passion for chemistry
yet, and you will find it.
Maybe you'll find
it this semester.
Maybe it will be
next year at MIT.
Maybe it won't be for
years until you're
an engineer and all of a sudden
you're working with chemists
and you're like,
oh, man, I really
need to understand chemistry to
do my engineering job better,
and then that's when
you fully appreciate
the value of chemistry.
But I hope that if you haven't
found your passion yet,
you will find it this
semester, and I'm
going to try to help you
understand why chemistry
is so amazing and
how it can affect
all sorts of
different disciplines.
And so if you really
embrace it and look at it,
you realize there's just
wealth of information
that is in there.
And if you get these
main tools that we're
going to cover-- I'm
going to teach you really
all the basics that you need
to know-- if you can get those,
you can go on and do all sorts
of things with that chemistry.
And I have a
7-year-old daughter,
and the world is a pretty
scary place right now.
There are a lot of problems
associated with it,
and we need people who
understand chemistry
to make the world better
and to make the world better
for my daughter.
So this is a very
personal exercise for me.
I want everyone to come out of
the class with this background
in chemistry that they
can save the world,
because the world needs saving
and my daughter is really cute,
and I'd like to show a picture
of her and say, make this world
a better place for her.